[Musique]
les candidats des républicains sont des
candidats qui ont un ancrage territorial
c'est cela qui fait notre notre force
notre responsabilité c'est de trouver
des solutions de s'engager pour moi
c'est vraiment important pour le débat
démocratique que nous soyons présents à
l'Assemblée nationale élu de terrain je
suis en responsabilité et en proximité
il ne faut pas oublier les habitants du
territoire rural qui ont des besoins
équivalents au milieu urbain j'ai
l'ambition de me battre pour redonner la
parole au maire et aux habitants et il
faut absolument croire dans notre
famille politique ces élections doivent
l'occasion d'engager un renouveau
civique je crois aussi que ces valeurs
de loyauté de sincérité de fidélité sont
aussi des valeurs que nous devons porter
en politique au tribunal de commerce
j'ai pu toucher du doigt cette détresse
profonde et se manque moyenne flagrant
de la justice à travers mes mandats je
connais vos difficultés
ont des défis à relever et notamment
l'accès aux
soins d'accompagner les habitants au
quotidien afin de défendre leurs
intérêts mais je veux aussi agir sur le
retour de la méritocratie et la remise
en route de l'ascenseur social demain à
l'Assemblée nationale je veux faire
remonter mon territoire je veux le faire
avancer les républicains ont une voix
apportée nous incarnons le parti de la
responsabilité nous incarnons le parti
de l'ancrage territorial je connais mon
territoire ses habitants leurs
difficultés leurs attentes et les
projets qu'ils appellent de leur vœu
c'est ma conception du rôle de députés
il faut voter LR c'est le choix de la
responsabilité c'est le choix de
l'engagement c'est le choix de
l'assurance de la réforme avec des gens
qui sont au contact de nos concitoyens
qui vivent sur leur circonscription qui
comprennent les préoccupations de chacun
et c'est fort de ses enseignements de
cette proximité avec nos compatriotes et
bien que nous serons capables de faire
vivre le débat l'assemblée et surtout de
faire de pouvoir modifier les textes et
d'avoir enfin les réformes qui
nécessaire pour notre pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]